サッブパッパスアカラナン クサラッさウパサンパダサチッタパリヨダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
はい これからの今日のテーマについて
一つかのアイディアを出してみたいと思います
えっと テーマはかっこいいんですけど
先生面白くないと思いますよ
僕は うーん それから ちょっと難しくなる可能性もあります
あの自由という言葉になりますかね
自由という言葉が出てくると
そちらの反対はまあ執着ということですね
執着 束縛が自由の反対です
自由の経験は誰にもないんです
ただ 単語を使ってますよ
すごく そんな経験ないんです
誰にも だから自由っていうのは言葉だけで
政治的にでもね 世の中で自由なんかは存在しないんです
自由と謳っている国々の方が
ものすごく一般国民も徹底的に束縛されているんです
管理されているんです
言うとおりに動くしかもうどうしようもないんです
執着 束縛について学ぶんです
ですから 我々は毎日経験している執着
束縛とは何かと 束縛のメリット
デメリット なぜ現れるのか
どのように出すのかと学ぶ必要があります
だから いきなり経験したこともない
よくわかる 全くわからない自由を目指すんじゃなくて
何からの自由でしょうかと
なんでその自由が得なくちゃいけないかとかね
そこをはっきりするのは仏教的なアプローチなんですね
納得したならば 束縛を断つための意欲が生じます
束縛が良くないと危険であるとわかったら
あ 束縛を断つた方がいいなという欲が出てくるんですね
そこでこの本質的な意欲がなければないとなかなかできるものでもないんです
怠ることなく運ぶ人のみ
自由の安らぎに達します
誰でも簡単に自由になれるわけじゃないんですね
かなり束縛がひどいもんですから
かなり勇気を振り絞って頑張らなくてはいけないということでもありますね
はい ではこれから政治的な束縛ではなくて
経済的な束縛ではなくてね
仏教的に束縛って何なのかと
これから学んでいこうかなと思いますね
はい それには仏教用語でウパーダーナという言葉がありまして
ウパーダーナ 意味は執着ですね
束縛 執着とは簡単な言葉ではありません
これはそんな簡単に理解できる単語ではありません
心の認識機能機能を精密に知り尽くした上で語られています
仏教の場合はね ただ この政治的経済的な束縛っていうのはそんな大したことではありませんからね
でお釈迦様がこれは心の問題ですと
だから心の働きを徹底的に知り尽くした上で
束縛について語られています
でお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
できるだけ経典省略していますが
チャッタリマニビッキーウパーダーナニカタマニチャッタリ
カームーパーダーナン
ディットゥパーダーナン
シーラッブトゥパーダーナン
アッタワーデュパーダーナンという 4つですね
意味は執着は 4種類です 1
カームパーダーナン 欲
いわゆる五欲ですね への執着
にディットゥパーダーナン
見解への執着 サン シーラッブトゥパーダーナン 4
アッタワーデュパーダーナン
シーラッブトゥパーダーナンというのは儀式
儀礼 行などへの執着 アッタワーデュパーダーナンというのはなかなか訳しにくい難しい単語で
まあ我 自我ですね 我論
我について執着しています
この 4つをまず 4つであると 5
つはありません だから執着といったら一つでもありません
必ず 4つなんです はい
それから説明していきましょうか
カームパーダーナン 五欲への執着
ここでの欲とは感情のことでありません
欲といったら感情になりますけどね
心の状態ですね カーマウパーダーナンという場合は
カーマ欲とは感情のことじゃないんです
眼耳鼻舌身という感覚器官に触れる色声香味触法という情報のことです
要するに見えるもの 聞こえるもの
味わえるもの 嗅ぐもの
嗅ぐもの 味わえるもの
体に触れるものを欲と呼ぶんです
で このこのセット 本当はパーリ語で暗記した方が
仏教は早く早く勉強することは理解することができるようになるんです
あのチャックソータガーナジーハーカーエ
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身ですね
に触れるルーパサッデガンダラサポッタッブ
というものです 感覚器官もそれらに適する対象も物質です
面白いんですね 目耳鼻っていうのは仏教から見れば物質です
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
味わえるもの 嗅ぐもの
それも物質です ものですよ
結局は  5つの対象に執着すること
依存することを 一般的に言う欲ですね
だから一般的にも欲というのは
その品物に欲とは言わないんです
これ欲しいんですね だから欲しいという気持ちに
一般世界では欲というんですね
この場合は カームというのはこの品物のこと
ウパーダーナっていうのはそれに束縛されていること
生存するために対象に依存するんです
大変なことになってます
我々は生き延びるために
目に耐えられなくちゃいけないし
耳に耐えられなくちゃいけないし
ご飯食べる場合はね 味やら香りやら
そういうものが耐えられなくちゃいけないんですね
大変なことになってます
耐えられなくちゃ だから
要するに依存しなくちゃいけないことになっていますね
で あの だから私たちは一般的に言うね
あんた欲張り なんでそんなにそれに執着しているのかとか
あれやこれやと言うんだけど
その程度の話じゃないんです
私はそんな欲がありませんよという人もいるでしょ
そんな冗談の話 もっと根本的な話なんですね
生きる上で 見るもの 聞くもの
嗅ぐもの 味わい ものを体に触れるものがなければ
どうやって生きていられますかね
生きるとは そういうことに頼っていることでしょう
結局 そういう欲 ものに依存しているんですね
そこに愛着が生まれるだったら
ウパーダーナというんですね
だから愛着が生まれるんですよ
はい 次 あの まあそれぐらいですね
カーマ・ウパーダーナは
すぐ別な角度から説明していきます
パッサという言葉 パッサ
意味は触れること 眼耳鼻舌体に色声香味触法が触れるんです
この場合は五じゃなくて六つも使っているんです
この説明には六つも使わなくては
ちょっと説明がちょっと壊れるんです
で 別な経典にこの点を参考にしてるんです
眼耳鼻舌身意 いわゆる六根というんですね
それに色声香味触法が触れるんです
前の説明で この意というところと法という項目をちょっと抜けて５つにしてたんです
五欲と そこであの 触れるという単語が二回出てくるんですね
体に触れることと 目耳鼻に触れることと
だから同じことだから
パッサという同じ言葉を使いますけど
ちょっと意味が違うんですね
これが意味が何だろうと困るのはこういうことなんですね
目に見えるものを触れる
まあそれはわかりますね
耳に音が触れる それもわかります
舌に味が触れる 次なんです
体に触が触れる なんだこれっていう風になっちゃうんですね
ですから この体に触れる触とは同じものじゃないんです
体に何が触れるんですかね
耳には音でしょ 体に何が触れるんですかね？体に触れるのは
例えば私はね 手にこうやってこのテーブルを触ったりしますね
触れてますね 手にテーブルが触れてます
本当はテーブルが触れてません
この硬さを触れているんです
硬くないと じゃあ空気をこうやって触れることできる？できないね
硬くないと しかし すごく風が吹くと
硬いんです 空気が だから大量に空気が触れてますから
量が多いんですね そうすると硬く感じて触れるんですね
あまりにも空気の方が強くなっちゃうと
触れすぎちゃって倒れますよ
人に倒す 倒されたような感じで
だから体に触れるのは硬さ
硬さが強いんだったら硬いという
自分が期待する硬さと
比較したら それほど硬くないという場合はソフト柔らかいと言うんです
だから柔らかいと言ったっても
硬さでチェックしているんです
どの程度の硬さでしょうかと
だから頭の中で妄想概念で標準硬さがないと
その言葉言えないんです
例えば布を一つ いろんな人にこれ触ってみて
これ触ってみて これ触ってみてと頼んだら
ある人はこれ柔らかい
まあまあ これは普通でしょう
いや これちょっと硬いんじゃない？とか意見言うでしょ
同じ布 一切れ触ってみても
で ご飯食べる場合も ああ
ちょうどいいという人を見て
ちょっと硬いんじゃない？これちょっと柔らかすぎという人を見ますね
だから同じ釜でご飯炊いて
2  3人  6人に食べてもらったら
どうですかと 炊き具合はとというと
一人がちょっと硬 これはちょっと柔らかと
あ これはまあちょうどいいと言うでしょ
だから その各人の頭の中で妄想概念ですけど
標準の硬さがあって それと比較するんですね
だから標準硬さと同じだったら
あ ちょうどいいぐらいという標準硬さより硬さが低いんだったら
これは柔らかいというんですね
標準硬さより硬いんだったら
これ硬いというんですね
だから科学根拠はないんです
硬い 柔らかいという場合は
実験室では硬さをいろんなね
まあ計算する方法あります
どれぐらいの圧力 何キロ
何グラムでしたとか あれやこれやとあるかもしれませんだけど
じゃああと髪の毛 1本切るまではどれぐらい力が必要ですかと
40本の髪の束を切るためにはどれぐらい力が必要でしょうかとかね
これ機械で計算することはできますね
その場合は数字で硬さが表してますけど
それは人間が感じる感覚の硬さとは違うんですね
まあそれでも調べるのは硬さなんですね
そういうわけでもう一つあります
体で触ってみて あ 熱い
あ 冷たい あ 普通というでしょ
それも体で感じます 熱いと感じたら
自分の頭にある標準 熱度というんですか
標準温度より高い 頭のある標準温度より高い
だから暑いという 頭にある標準温度より低いんだったら冷たいというんです
頭にある標準温度と温度と同じ温度だったら何も感じない
気づかない はい そういうことで体で感じるのはたった 2つです
硬さと熱 硬さと熱だけです
大したことないんです
すごいつまらないんです
体で 指先でいろんなものを感じて
あれができる これができると言ったっても
大したデータではないんです
はい そういうことで このパッサっていうのは体に対して即という感じ使ってますけど
本当は硬さと温度なんです
だから目に色と形が触れる
鼻に香りが触れる 耳に音が触れる
舌に味が触れる 体に硬さと熱が触れる
そう言うと 触れるという単語がダブらないんです
なんでダブるようにしているのかというと
誰がみんないたって簡単に体のことは触った
触れたと言うんですね
だからみんな一般的にその単語を使っているんだから
仏教用語でまあその単語を使う
とにかく 1つの単語を使わなくちゃいけない
2種類触れるんだけど
しかし 私たちはそれだけですかね
知っているのは 結構たくさんのことを知ってますね
だから五感はもう決まってるんです
あの知ってるたくさんのこと
過去のことも思い出す
将来のことも思考する
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみを感じる
考えたりもする そういうものは
意識ですね  6番目 意識で感じるんです
心で感じるんです 心で感じるものは必ずなくてもいいんです
存在しなくても心で思考することはできます
とは言いますけど 結局はあれも合成なんですね
怪獣のことをイメージすることができます
でも怪獣はいません 龍のことをイメージすることができます
描くこともできます しかし
存在しません 将来のイメージを作ることができます
しかし その通りにあるわけじゃないし
将来はもうないんです
今はないのに頭でイメージすることができます
というわけで すごい一般的にないものも意識で認識しますよというんです
だからよく見ると あれはないものじゃないんです
かつて過去であったもの
経験したものは組み合わせるんです
この龍っていうのは 実際
世の中にあるいろんな動物たちの部品を合わせた変なイメージなんです
だから我々は将来のことをイメージしても
過去の経験いろいろ組み合わせて作った絵なんですね
描いた絵なんです 頭の中で
だから私たちの将来のイメージっていうのは
結局 よう見ると過去なんです
今日も昨日もね NSK でかなり文句言ってたんですけど
このうなぎがね あの レッドレーベルになってしまったと
あ 大変だ これは とか まあこれから皆様方みんな飢え死になると思います
うなぎ食べられなくなって
そんな感じで 喋ってるんですね
世界のうなぎね の 3 4食ってるんだけどね
人間 うなぎは人間食べる食料の一つというならば
世界中どんな人間にも食べる権利があるでしょ
日本人だけ食べて いくつかの国々でうなぎ食べてますけど
その国々にも文句言って
だから我々のうなぎは取れなくなったとか
すごいんですね この それで私が言いたいのは
今皆様に今ここでうなぎの蒲焼食べていることをイメージできない
その味を再現してイメージすることできない
その香りを再現することできない
できますね うなぎの蒲焼の香りと味と感触とイメージすることはできます
しかし よく見てください
あれ 過去の経験を復活しただけなんです
これから食べようとするうなぎの香り
味をイメージしてくださいといったら
これはできないんです
しかし 仏教ではこの存在しないものだから
結局は 存在しないものも意識で認識できますよと
例えば私に目を閉じて
こうやってここら辺 目を閉じて
このこれを触って あ テーブルだと認識することはできます
この場合は現在 今ここにあるものなんですね
そういうことで あるものもないものも
過去のものも現在のものも
将来のものも 心で認識することはできます
これで問題は 我々は頭で考えることはすごく信頼するんです
目に見える 耳に聞こえるものよりも
全然信頼にならないんです
頭で考えるものは 触ったものは
これ熱いと言ったら もうそれなりに測ってみることもできますからね
はい それで胃に触れるものには
仏教は全部まとめて 現象っていう意味で法と書くんですね
あの法という漢字使っている理由は
瞑想すると心はどんどん成長して
サマーディとかね 一度も経験したことのないもの
それから涅槃とかね そういうものも体験できる
サマーディはそういう状態は存在する
で作れる で 涅槃も真理としてある現象だとしているんですね
事実として だからこのそういうものも一応心で認識しなくちゃいけないんですね
それ全て入れて心に認識可能なもの
すべてまとめると単語がないんだから
すべて入る単語は法という単語なんです
何も漏れない その単語で
パーリ語でダンマーと言うんですね
それを使っているんです
はい それで話が相当難しくなったので
ちょっとまとめましょう
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触
法が触れる コンタクトする
それは因果法 因果を教えているところで
サラヤタナパッチャヤパッソウと書いてありますね
普通の日本訳は六根によって触が起こるなんですね
今説明したのは このサラヤタナパッチャヤパッソウ
我々の 6つの感覚器官に情報が触れるということです
だから  6つの感覚器官があれば触が生まれるんです
この体に 触れたら感じるんですよ
触れたこと 感じなきゃ何のこともないんです
触れたら感じる それは因果法則でパッサパッチャウェーダナーというんです
そこによって受が起こると
ま 受という漢字がなんで
書くんですかね よくわかりません
感覚なんですね それで目で感じる
耳で感じる 鼻で感じる
体で感じる わかりやすいでしょ
感じることにはパーリ語でウェーダナーというんです
感じた 感じたことに対して渇愛が生じるんです
ウェーダナーパッチャヤタンハー
受によって渇愛が起こる
この渇愛といったらすっごくややこしい単語で
この渇ですから 渇きですから
あってもあっても足らない
満足しないという意味なんですね
これがごく不自然 不自然ではなくて
自然なことで で 何か味わったら
まあもうこれでいいんだよとは思えないんです
再び味わいたくなる 一回音楽を聴いたら
もう二度と聞きません
もう十分であるとは思えないんです
また必要になるんです
いわゆる生きるために
すーっと聞かなくちゃいけない
すーっと見なくちゃいけない
すーっと鼻を使わなくちゃいけない
ずっと味を使う 味を感じなくちゃいけない
ずっと体で感じなくてはいけない
味などはもう 24時間感じるわけじゃないんだけど
でも舌はいつだって感じられる状態でいるんです
体ではずっと感じていますね
目でずっと絶えず感じていますね
目を閉じて寝る時以外は
耳もいつでも構えているんです
音が入ったら感じてやるぞと
だから寝たら目が一旦休止しますけど
耳の方が開いておくんです
音が入ったら聞いてやるぞと
音を入って聞いた途端
脳が動き出しちゃって目が覚めるんです
だから寝ている人を目覚めさせるために目を開けてあげたら大丈夫
全然目覚めませんよ 目覚めると言うんだけどね
起きると言うんだけど
目を無理やり開けたら人が起きるわけじゃないんです
体振ったりするか 喋るかどちらかなんです
そちらは窓口開いてます
24時間 そうでないと生きていられないんです
だからこの活という単語が存在するためにかなり大事な働きなんです
なんで活愛になるんでしょうかというと
これ 生きるということは絶えず起きる
絶えず起きる出来事なんです
休止はないんです 休憩はないんです
心臓と同じです ずっと行動しなくちゃいけないんです
止まったらもう死ぬんです
細胞に酸素を送ることも同じでしょ
休みがないんです 細胞に栄養を与えることも同じなんです
食べるのは 3食かもしれませんだけど
体の中はそうはダメです
スーッと血液の血液の中で栄養成分が流れているんです
だから生きるということは絶えず起きている出来事なんです
止まらないんです 本当に面倒くさいんだけど
どうしようもないんです
だから生きるっていうことは
休みのない作業なんです
なんでそうなっているのかというと
お釈迦様はいたって簡単に
すべてのものごとは無常ですと
だから体無常です 一回何かやって結果が起きても
それが無常だからすぐ消えるんです
またやらなくちゃいけないんです
ご飯食べても無常だからもう消えちゃうんです
またやらなくちゃあかんです
そういうことで 自然法則的にすべての生命に渇愛が生まれる
です これで愛という単語が欲ということになるでしょ
これで欲しいということの方が多いんだから力が多いんだだからその単語を使っているんです
だから欲しくないという気持ちにも同じ欲と呼ぶんです
何か食べたらその味が欲しくない
気に入らない その場合も渇愛というんです
だから好きな音楽を聴いてると渇愛が生まれる
あまり聞きたくはない音楽を聴いちゃうと
欲は生まれませんよと言っても
仏教ではやっぱり渇愛が起きているんです
聞きたくないという 渇愛が生まれているんです
だから渇愛っていうのは
仏教では一つの単語 タンハー
タンハーといえば渇きって意味なんです
愛は入ってないんです
渇きなんです それだったらぴったしなんです
だからまあしょうがないんですよ
日本語にしちゃうと 渇きだけでも十分です
では 何か食べようと思ったところで
食べたものはものすごくまずくて
もう嫌なんですね そうすると食べたいという渇きがそのままなんですね
食べたいという渇きがちょこっと強烈になっているんです
これではダメですよとはなってないんです
だからおいしいものが食べると
ああ おいしい おいしい
食べたい 食べたい気持ちが生まれるのはわかりやすい
食べたいのにまずいものを食べる羽目になっちゃうと
おいしいものを食べたい気持ちがさらに強烈になるんです
これは嫌やと だから２日間 ３
日間 なんかつまらないものを食べた人が ３
日目で金払って結構いいものを食べちゃうんです
食べ過ぎになっちゃうんで
だから渇愛が溜まってるんです
ダイエットする人々はなんでリバウンドするんですかね
食べたいのに食べないでいるんですね
それで食べたいという渇愛が大きくなっているんです
それで我慢できなくなってリバウンドしてしまう
だから 耳に音が触れても
舌に味が触れても同じことで
渇愛が増えるばっかしなんです
目を楽しみたいと 美しいものを見て
公園を見たり 花を見たり
映画を見たり あれやこれやとかね
そこで美しいものを見ると
あー気持ちいい 気持ちいいということになりますが
あんまり見られなくなっちゃうと
もう見たくてたまらないという渇愛が生まれ
強烈になっているんです
というわけで 美しいものを見えても渇愛が生まれる
美しくないものを見えても渇愛が生じる
だから愛がなんかややこしいんですね
渇きが生じる そういう複雑な働きなんです
複雑じゃないんです すごいシンプルです
渇きが何やっても増すばかり
それで渇きそのものを分析すると３種類になるんです
1番目は物が欲しいという渇き
命を支えるために 食べ物を見る
ものを聞く ものを欲しい
触れるものを欲しい この渇きは消えません
2番目は生きていきたいという
これ いくらやっても生きることは瞬間の出来事だから
また頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
絶えず頑張らなくちゃいけない
だから存在欲は決して消えません
80年生きていたっても
生きていきたい欲が増えるんであって
減ることはないんです
だから 死が近寄ってくると
存在欲がものすごく強烈になるんです
それが死ぬのは怖いということで現れてくるんです
誰だって死ぬのは怖いと思ってるでしょ
だから存在欲も増えるばっかしで減りません
3番目は非存在欲と私は日本語訳しますけど
うーん これのね 著作集などの難しい解説定義いろいろあるんですけど
それはまああんまり一般人にはわからないし
非存在欲っていうのは
ちょっと人生を見てみたら
もう嫌で嫌で もう納得いかない
そこで人がもっと面白い
もっと楽しい人生ないのかという人もいて
逆にこんなのはもう大嫌い
嫌やときれいさっぱり処分したいと
というふうな気持ちが
それも渇愛なんです もう嫌になっちゃってる
それが非存在欲なんですね
それも渇愛なんです 渇きです
そんな勝手にこの存在はこりごりやと言ったっても
そんなうまくいくわけがないんです
例えば最近ね ものすごい雨が降るようになっちゃってね
地滑りやらいろんな問題あるでしょうに
嫌でしょ あんなのは だからと
どうにもならん そういう風に
時々私たちはこれさえなければ
あれさえなければという気持ちはあるでしょう
あれも渇きなんです だから 3種類ですね
なぜこの関係ないことを言ってるんでしょうかね
私は すべての仏教のこの教えの中心点は
このウェーダナパッチャータンハというフレーズにかかっているんです
ビッグバンから宇宙が現れたと同じく
仏教の教えも解脱涅槃もウェーダナパッチャータンハというところから出発するんです
これは仏教のビッグバンなんです
ウェーダナパッチャータンハ
感覚によって渇きが生じる
正しい訳は 感覚によって渇きが生じる
そこから輪廻というビッグバンが
渇愛が生じると執着が生じるんです
それなんです それから束縛
もう逃げない もう乾いたいるんだからね
それで渇きから執着が生まれるんです
はい これが今日のテーマですね
線を引いておきました
タンナーパチャウパーダナ
渇愛によって執着が起こる
もう自由がないんです
もう束縛です 犯人が渇きなんです
タンナーなんです 原因は
だから束縛が嫌だなと思うならば
この渇きとは何かと学んで
それをなくすんです 渇きなくすと束縛が消えてしまいます
それを言いたかったんです
それはもう仏教のセントラルティーチングというんです
いわゆる中心的な教えです
心臓部です 仏教の 今説明したところは
ストップ 制御できるところは
目などがあると いやおうなしに情報が触れる
どうしようもないでしょ
制御できません 目があると触れる
耳があると音を触れる
いやおうなしに感じる
コントロールできません
誰にもストップできません
しかし それなりに訓練
理解 能力 智慧があれば
あるならば 渇愛 タンナーが起きないようにすることができるんです
渇愛は制御できるんです
簡単じゃないんです 渇愛が起きても執着しないようにするのは無理です
はい 渇愛を放っておいて
渇き状態 もっと食べたいな
もっと聞きたいな もっと美味しいものを食べたいな
もっと美しいものを見たいなという
その気持ちを置いたままで
世の中にある束縛を捨てましょうと言ったら
これはアホな話でありえないんです
もっと欲しいという渇愛を制御するんです
人々は認識過程を観察することなく
苦しみの原因になる流れに身を任せて生きているんです
しかし 世の中で人間誰一人もこれは調べない
仏教以外は 仏教の場合も
お釈迦様の教えを実践する人々以外は興味ないんです
みんな渇愛を増える方法を生きてるんです
死んでも永遠に天国に行くぞとかね
死んだら必ず極楽道に往生できるぞとかね
あるいはみんなもともと悟ってるんだとか
天台的な考えで だからいい加減に生きていても大丈夫やとかね
どんどん渇愛を増える方向へ喋ってるんです
減る方法に行かないんですね
みんな流れに身を任せてるんで
どんな流れかというと
渇きの流れに 悩み 苦しみの流れに身を任せているんです
仏教は逆に泳いで早く岸に行きなさいと言っている世界です
次のテーマ 自分に執着するという
命とは五蘊 パンチャッカンダです
だいたい皆様は五蘊という単語を聞いたことありますね
だから今日はあんまりこのめんどくさいんだから
私の単語を入れる いろいろやつの結構時間かかっちゃうしね
いろんなアイデアを考えなくちゃいけないし
めちゃめんどくさくて
まあ経典に沿って講演を作ったんですね
だからもう専門用語ばっかしになるんです
私 私という私の命っていうのは
仏教用語では五蘊というんです
色受想行識というんですね
さっさと説明しますけど
色蘊というのは肉体のこと
受蘊というのは感覚のこと
サンニャ 想蘊というのはたくさん概念を持っていること
サンカーラ いわゆる行蘊というのは
衝動があること 生きていきたい
やりたい やりたいというね
それから 5番目 認識 認識する
これは命とものの差なんですね
ものは認識しない 命は認識する
そうやってこの 5つのシステムがありまして
一個一個それぞれのシステムなんです
だから五蘊というんです
いわゆる 5つのシステムですね
この 5つのシステムを合わせたら
私 私の命 なんだらかんだらで言うんです
それに五取蘊 パンチパーダーナカンダとも言います
五蘊五蘊ではなくて よく使う単語は五取蘊なんです
そちらも執着の執が入ってるんです
ウパーダーナという言葉が
パンチャウパーダですから
正しく言えば五執着蘊なんです
執着する五蘊という意味ですね
だって自分の体好きでしょ？体に執着しているでしょ？自分の感覚が好きでしょ
執着しているでしょ からまとめると
自分に執着するってことなんです
ということはどういうこと？世の中があなたを束縛しているのかいと言えば
あれ違うんじゃない？自分が自分に執着しているんですね
だから世の中のことに依存しなくちゃいけなくなっているんです
だから そんな軽々く自由自由でいたってもね
あんた自分に執着している限りは諦めなさいなんです
ありえないんです はい
それから別な経典を紹介します
これはある尼さんと 尼さんは阿羅漢ですけど
ウィサーカという男性の信者さん
その方も預流果一来果程度にまで悟ってはいたんです
ダンマディンナアマさんは阿羅漢なんです
で ウィサーカがダンマディンナ比丘に問います
五取蘊が執着ですか 執着は五取蘊と別なものですかと
いわゆる自分が執着ですか
執着は自分と違うものですかと
別々なものですかと聞くんです
答え 五取蘊は執着ではありません
執着は五取蘊と別なものでもありませんと
どういう どちらでもありませんと
難しいでしょうね はい
そこで新しい単全面用語が割り込みます
チャンドラーゲン まあ軽く漢文で漢字で愛欲と書きますけど
意訳する意訳ではなくて
直訳するならば これ好きという漢字を入れて
好欲と言った方が正しいんです
好むと欲 でも使ってないんだから
そういう単語はね で 答え続きます
五取蘊に対するチャンドラーゲン
いわゆる愛欲が執着 ウパーダーナですと
いわゆる体のこと好きなんですよ
まあ別に肉体でしょう
こんなのは変わって変わっていくものだから
管理もできんしね 放っておこうということになっちゃうと
愛欲がないんです どうって壊れるんだからと
それで感覚にしたっても
感覚というのはずっと変化するものでしょ
あてにならない 何を触っても
触ったものによって感覚が変わる
この感覚が好きだなというふうに執着することはあてにならない
そうやって放っておけばいいんですけど
我々は放っておくことの反対
ああ これいいなと欲を作るんです
愛欲を作るんです 体に対して
五蘊に対して この愛欲にウパーダーナと言うんだよと
ネテーカーマ これは仏教の世界ではかなり人気のある偈ですね
ネテーカーマヤーニチッターニローケーサンカップラーグープリサッスカーモ
これ別な経典です ティッタンティチッラーニタテーワローケーアテッタディーラヴィネヤンティチャンダン
世にある美しいものは欲ではありません
動くということ いい文章です
人の思考 概念が欲です
うなぎは美味しいではないんです
人間の気持ちなんです
花が美しいとか何だらかんだら関係ないんです
それぞれ植物は自分に合わせて何か形を作っているだけで
私たちは花が美しいというのは
自分たちの気持ちを表現しているんです
概念考えを表現しているんです
だから思考が欲なんです
世にある美しいものはそのまま置いて放っておいて
賢者はそれに対する愛欲を戒めるんですと
これで逆に俗っぽく言えば
あの花がきれいだから欲しくなったと
花のせいにする あの女性がとても美しいんだから
私に欲が生まれたんだと
女性のせいにするんです
この食べ物はあまりにもごちそうで美味しかったんだから
食べたいと欲が生まれたんだ
食べ物のせいにする あれは間違いです
食べ物は何もやってないんです
道路を歩いている女性が何の悪いこともしていないんです
ストーカーにされることは何もやってないんです
私はストーカーこうやったのは
この女が悪いやとへっちゃらで言ってるでしょ
私のことを無視したんだから殺しちまったと
だから相手が悪いと 人殺しでそう言うんです
その同じことを我々もまとめの人間がと言い張ったりはするんだけど
そうやってます お前がうるさいんだから私は怒ってるでしょうと
お前が言うことを聞かないんだから
私は怒っているでしょうにと
あなたは仕事を間違ったんだから私は怒っているでしょうと
そうやって世の中いっそでも他人のせいにする
世の中はそのままなんです
仕事を失敗した人が上司を怒らせようという気持ちはないんです
怒った上司は勝手に怒ったんです
そのポイントをこの経典で言っているんです
だから 智慧のある人が世の中のことを放っておいて
自分のところで今求めるんだよと
愛着が生まれませんように
愛欲が生まれないようにと
いわゆるまあ 放っておくという
私の言葉では放っておいてよと
これはサンガティニカディープサンゲットの 4番目の経典です
また 尼さんの経典に戻ります
なんか尼さんが説法するとね
えらい難しいんですよ
もうどういうことですかね
経典にありますからね
阿羅漢の何人かの説法は
ビシッとポイントに行っちゃうんですね
詳しく説明しようという気持ちはないんです
男性はガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ分析して詳しく説明するんで
ですから 今日の説法は皆様に女性の方々にはいたって簡単に理解できると思います
尼さんの経典は中心にして全部残ったんです
人生は楽しいだけではありません
体で感じる感覚は この場合は体っていうのは目
耳 鼻 全部なんです 感覚は 1 楽
2 苦  3 不苦不楽です だから感じるものは 3つのカテゴリーに入ります
だから人生は楽だけじゃないんです
楽はまあ 3つに分けるんだったら 3分の1ですけど
データ取っちゃうとそんなもんじゃないんです
ちゃんと感覚をデータに分けてみると
楽の方がものすごい大量なんです
それで  1 について学びましょう
スカヴェーダナとパーリ語で言うんです
1 いわゆる楽の感覚 楽の感覚がある場合
ある場合 いわゆる今ある場合
ある場合は楽しい 当たり前ですね
あー気持ちいい 気持ちいいと楽しいんです
なくなると苦です なくなっちゃうと苦しいんです
だから恋する時は楽しいでしょ
振られたらすごく苦しくなっちゃうんですね
そこで楽しい感覚起きている時は欲の繊細煩悩が起こるんです
繊細煩悩というのは溜まるんです
それは 欲が心の中でどんどん溜まっていくんです
だから恋している時は本人が気づいてないんだけど
大量に欲の煩悩が溜まって溜まっていくんです
そこで振られた瞬間で
ものすごい苦しいんです
苦しみの感覚生まれるんです
はい  2番目に行きましょう
ドゥッカウェーダナ 苦の感覚
ある時は苦しいんですよ
例えば病気になったら苦しい
怪我したら苦しい お腹が空いたら苦しい
怒鳴られると苦しい ある時は苦しい
このある時っていうのは存在するときなんですね
現実としてある時 受けている時って
ちょっとこの単語 ちょっと曖昧だから別な単語を考えたんだけど
思い浮かばなかったんです
まあ英語だったら When it is present
ある時 ある時といえば
私は英語で考えるんだから
このサムタイムズという意味もありますね
ワンデーとか ある時 このあの人は怒っちゃったんだよと One
day he got mad. とかね
我々はそういう日本語はそうやって訳するんです
時々はサムタイムズですね
その意味じゃないんです When
it is present
今ある時 です 苦しみの感覚を感じている時は苦です
怪我したら苦しいんです
怒鳴られたら苦しいんです
なくなると楽しい 病気になったら苦しい
病気がなくなると楽しい
楽です ある時は怒りの繊細煩悩が起こるんです
そこで苦しいを苦しみを感じる時は
心の中でものすごく怒りが溜まって溜まっていくんです
だから機嫌が悪いでしょ
健康な時よりは病気な時は機嫌が悪いんで
もう怒ってるんです 問題は 3番目なんですね
アドゥッカマスカウェーダナ
いわゆる不幸 不楽なんですね
楽しくもない 楽でもない時
どうですかね だから楽しくもない
楽でもないんだから これ知ると楽しいんです
今はまあ普通ですよと
落ち着いてますよと ああ
今楽しいというよりも
今楽しくもないし 苦しくもなくて
普通 それ観察すると楽しみが生まれてくるんです
無知は苦です これわからないでしょう
みんな退屈というでしょう
何もやることなくなっちゃうと
ああ 退屈だ あれ無知ですから
何もないことを観察すると楽しくなるんです
やる仕事もないし 見るテレビ
見たいテレビ番組もないし
まあ読みたい本もないし
あ 何もやることはなく
ただいればいい それ結構楽しいんですよ
ものすごくリラックスするんです
しかし 皆様どうするかというと
ああ 嫌だ これはもうやることなくて
退屈だ 何とかしなくちゃとかなっちゃうんです
だから無知です その場合は
それで苦しみになっちゃうんです
風雨苦 風楽は そこでどんな煩悩が生まれるんですかね
派手な楽しい感覚もない
派手な苦しい感覚もない
その時 無明が繊細煩悩として生まれる
これは瞑想する人々にとってもものすごい問題なんですね
瞑想を始めたら慣れてないんだから
肉体がもう痛くてしょうがないんです
それで嫌で嫌で嫌でろくにやらない
それでも私の顔を見ると
みんな虎の顔を見たような楽しい気分になるんだから
あの虎は私が勝手に皆様は別な動物にしたいでしょうと思いますけどね
それは聞かないことにして
私はかっこいい虎にします
で そういう気分になるんだから
やっぱり瞑想するんです
瞑想をどんどんすると苦しみが消えるんです
消えると別に楽しいわけでもないんだけど
苦しいわけでもない それでやる気がなくなっちゃって
寝ているんです もう眠気にやられているんです
立っていても寝ているんだと
いるんですよ もう立っているのに
ガクッて歩いているのに
眠気で ものすごい無明の煩悩が溜まっているんです
無知の煩悩が そこで人生正しくデータを取ってみると
楽しい瞬間というのはそんなにたくさんないんです
すごい苦しい これそれもそんなにたくさんないんです
楽しみよりはたくさんです
大変だとという感じがね
楽しみよりは大変たくさんなります
しかし どうったことない感覚が大量なんです
例えば 電車に乗って会社に行く
楽しい まあ別に苦しいはそうでもないでしょ
毎日のことだから 会社で仕事をする
楽しいかというと 別に楽しいということでもない
苦しいかと 別に慣れてるんだから苦しいわけでもない
しかし 会社で仕事をしている時は
もう自分にはちょっとおっかない仕事を頼まれると結構苦しいんですよ
どうしようか これはと
あるいは自分にとって楽チンでできる仕事を頼むと楽しくなるんです
では 会社の仕事で考えてください
楽チンでニコニコと仕事をできることはそれほどたくさんないんです
苦しくてもう死にそうになる仕事もそれほどたくさんないんです
よくあるのは まあまあごく普通の仕事なんです
だから我々感じる感覚の場合は
楽しみは少ない 苦しみはそれより多い
風雨苦風楽 は大量なんです
そこで煩悩で計算すると
欲はそれほど生まれません
怒りは結構生まれる 無知はものすごい生まれるんです
だから誰々年取るとバカで終わっちゃうんです
そこでもない人間に終わっちゃうんです
感覚に依存する限りは
煩悩 束縛 執着から離れることができないという意味なんですよ
だって感覚いつだってあるでしょ
体ある限り感じる 目がある限り感じる
耳がある限り感じる だったらあの煩悩がどんどん生まれる
どうしようもないんです
ハメられているんです
で 煩悩が生まれると もう渇愛です
執着です 束縛です もう自由がないんです
それでまた尼さんが説法します
感覚に対する例外もあるんだと
あの在家の人がぐちゃぐちゃ質問するんですよ
次に聞いた質問は すべての感覚を戒めるべきですかと
言ったら 尼さんはいい
例外やりますよと 苦楽
不苦不楽の場合は 欲 怒り
無明をなくすべきですね
それはなくすべきです
しかし サマーディから生まれる楽の感覚は例外です
例えば 瞑想して集中力が生まれてくる
ものすごい楽しみが生まれるんです
もう世界では感じられないぐらい桁違い
楽しみが生まれてくるんです
すごい楽しみ それが別に放っておきましょうよと
なぜならば 煩悩を抑えるんだから
抑えたんだからサマーディが生まれたんです
だからサマーディ瞑想から得る幸福感は戒める必要はないんです
それは大いに喜ぶでも構わないんです
例外です 心より上を目指して向上しなくては
解脱に達しなくてはと思うと
苦を感じる この仏道の人々は瞑想したり修行したりしますけど
これではダメだ 悟りに達しなくちゃ
もっと心成長しなくちゃ
もっと集中力を上げなくてはとかね
まあこのままでは嫌だなと思っちゃうでしょ
そうすると苦しいんです
苦を感じるんです しかし
それが例外です このままではダメ
あかん 解脱に達しなくちゃと思っちゃうと苦しいんですよ
状態は しかし その苦しみが例外です
なぜならば 煩悩は生じません
この人は煩悩をなくしたいと思っているんです
だからその苦しみも例外です
向上の線上に入ると 不苦不楽の感覚が生じる
線上にランクがあります
第一のランクですごく楽しくてたまらないんです
第二のランクに上がったら
楽しみが減って 寂しさが生まれてくるんです
第三のランクに上がったら
寂しさも減って なんか楽だなという
一般的な楽 まあ悪くないという感じになるんです
四番目に上がったら楽消えるんです
苦もないんです 初めから
いわゆる不苦不楽なんです
その不苦不楽の感覚も例外です
もう結構煩悩を抑えているんです
戒める必要ありません
例外です この尼さんの対話がこのマッジムニカへのチューラヴェーダッルスッタンというところに入ってます
はい 物に依存すること
詳しく説明したが 束縛の1は物に依存することです 1
カムパーダーナっていうのは
見るものに 食べるものに
着るものに 感じるものに
聞くものに依存する 物に依存する
鞄に依存する 服に依存する
まあいろいろ自分の時計に依存する
アクセサリーに依存するとかね
金に依存するとかね これ 1番目
物とは色声香味触です
当然それらは五根に触れる
感覚が起こる 仕方がありませんが
愛着 渇愛ですね タンナーだけは起こらないようにと戒めるんです
だからまあカバンは大事に使うのは構わないんだけど
こんなに愛着は やめた方がいいんです
金が必要だから使うんだけど
あんまり愛着しない方がいいってことになるんです
仏教の戒と律ははその目的で説かれているんです
仏教には戒律というものがありますね
本当は戒律っていうのは 2つなんです
戒と律なんです まとめて戒律
戒律と言うんだけどね
戒っていうのはやってはいけないこと
律はやるべきことなんです
これ結構詳しく勉強説明しててあります
皆様は一般的に戒律 禁止項目だと思っているんです
そうじゃないんです 禁止項目は戒で
行わなくてはいけない項目
条件は律で 例えば食べる時は
自分の肉体に必要な量をチェックして
その量だけ食べなさいと
食べてはいけないではないんです
そこで食べ方が出てくるんです
美味しい 美味しいと味に執着するんじゃないと
美味しさを感じるんだけど
執着はしない あるいはこの体を壊れるんだから
体に必要な材料を修復材料を取り入れますとというすごいクールな気持ちで食べなさいと
これは律なんです 寝るときも体の疲れを
肉体の疲れをなくすために横になりますと
体はだるい 修行できなくなっている
じゃあちょっと休み ませてあげますというやり方で寝る
ああ 寝ちゃおうかなとか
それダメです それも律数なんです
そんなのたくさんあります
戒よりは律数の方がたくさんです
歯の磨き方 顔の洗い方までもうきめ細かくてたくさんあります
便所の使い方とかね 服の着方とかね
脱ぎ方とかね 畳み方とかね
あるわあるわ もうすごい
部屋の掃除の仕方まであります
律数がたくさんです 戒は少ないんです
皆さんが知っているのは五戒 ５
つだけですからね 在家の方々というのはあまり律は言わないんです
出家には律は大量にあります
そこで一つ 目があるんだだから見えるでしょ
見える時にも戒があるんです
見る流れでは戒では戒
俺は戒といいますけどね
まあ目があるんだから
まあ見えるものはまあいいや
別にと しかし 欲と怒り使い作りませんよと
内でチェックする 花を見たら
うん まあきれいな花です
それで欲が なんてきれいな花ですか
感動感動はないんです
冷静でいるんです それで目の戒めになるんです
心は汚れない 音を耳があるんだから
音楽も入るし いろんな音入りますよ
人間だから耳障りのいい音もあって
耳障りの悪い音もあります
だから出家している人だからとね
音楽が流れると それはあの波長が人間の耳障りがいい
犬猫はすごい嫌いですけどね
覚えておいてください
音楽は で 人間にとってはすごい心地よい音ですけど
だから出家した人の耳にも音楽が触れると
心地よい音ですが 欲を作らないようにと
で そこでストップかけてガードするんです
それも戒なんです あるいは入ってる音はあんまりも耳障りですね
それだと怒りが生まれるんですね
出家はそこでガードマン入れておくんです
気づきという サティという入れて
音は入ってもいいんだけど
こちらで怒りが生まれないようにとチェックを入れておくんです
これで何がわかる？この 1番目の束縛を戒めるために戒律があるんです
戒と律があるんです サマタ瞑想で五欲を睡眠状態にすることができます
また方法あります このサマタ瞑想をする
呼吸瞑想とかなんとか
慈悲の瞑想は仏教は推薦する瞑想で
そういうサマタ瞑想すると五欲が睡眠状態になるんです
寝ちゃう 働かない 仮眠状態じゃ本当に睡眠状態になるんです
これは現代用語で言えばログアウトなんです
あのカーマ・ウパーダーナ
五欲への執着 ログアウトになるんです
ログアウトとはいつだってログインできる
それを覚えておいてください
サマタ瞑想すると 煩悩がロックアウトになるんです
だから心は綺麗ですが
すぐ必要な時ログインしちゃって元に戻しちゃうんです
えっと うーん まあ1時間ぐらいになりましたので
ちょっと休憩して2番目に行きます
では始まります 2番目の執着
これはディットーパーダーナント言いますね
見解への執着 誰にだって自分の考えがある
人は情報を認識するとき
心に概念が生じるんです
だって体から硬さと熱しか感じないでしょ
だから頭でテーブルだとなってるんです
そういう感じで頭の中で概念が起こるんです
概念をかき回して 自分の意見というものを作成します
いろいろ概念かき回すんですよ
例えばこのテーブルを見て
あ これは古いなとかね
あ そういえばこのホールもそんな新しいものではないとかね
そういう風にこの概念をかき回すんです
私はなんでこのテーブルが古いと思うんですかね
これ初めてではないんだけど
ここでしか見られない
これしか存在しないテーブルでしょ
古いでも新しいでも何とも言えないでしょ
でも いろんなところで新しいテーブルを見たことがあるでしょ
作ったばっかしの使ったばっかしのもの
その概念とこれを見て入った概念を合体させて
このテーブルが古いと
意見を作るんです 当然自分の意見は正しいんです
これは当然のこと 間違っていると発見したら意見が消えます
意見が間違っているとね
それは変えますよ 例えば人に目隠しをしてね
このテーブルのここら辺だけ触らせる
触って 何ですかと その人は
これ何か板じゃない？という
もう概念が現れたんですね
それで板 これはもう確か正しいと思ってるんです
それで目隠しを外しちゃうと
板ではなかったね テーブルなんですね
そうすると あ そうか テーブルかと
概念変えるんです というわけで
いつだって私たちの意見は正しいということになっちゃうんです
残念なことに 他人にも意見がありまして
それはほとんど私 私見にたまにしか合わない
残念ですね 他人にも意見がありますよ
これはほとんどの場合は私の意見と合わないんです
たまに合う時はありますけどね
自分の意見を守らなくてはならない
ですから 私の正しい意見を守らなくてはあかんでしょ
私見に執着する それで自分の意見に執着するんです
束縛される 怒り 嫉妬 悩み
憂い 苦しみなどなどが生じるんです
この意見っていうのは大変なもんで
誰にだってありますよ
意見持たない人っていないんです
目耳から情報入ったら
もうもう意見できてるんです
これが正しいと思ってるんですね
正しい 正しいと思ってはいるんだけど
人々が違う意見を持ってるんですね
で 自分の意見を守りに行くんです
あんたこう言ったってもとかね
あんたそう思ったってもとか
だって小学生の子供とお母さん喧嘩するでしょ？幼稚園の子供とお母さんが喧嘩するでしょ
子供は自分の意見正しいと思ってるんです
お母さんが自分の意見が正しいと思っているんです
これで喧嘩になるんです
ずっとあることなんです
私見とは すべての人はものは存在する
あるというスタンスで私見を作る
そこで私たちは意見を作る場合は
あるスタンスがあるんだよ
何何かがあると 存在すると
これは仏教ではあれは逆さまやと言ってるんです
データは あんたデータは逆さまにとってるんだと
だから意見は仏教は認めません
たまにものは存在しないという意見も起こるんです
たまに しかし 自分に対しては存在するに決まっている
で 例えば奇跡はあります
あんなの嘘でしょうと
っていう人はいるかもしれません
しかし 自分はいるんですよ
ある子供たちが中学生でしたけどね
このあの浄土 仏教の講義を聞かされてね
で 浄土の話やら阿弥陀さんの話やらいろいろいろいろね
それで子供たちの意見を取っていたんだよね
意見シート それである男の子が
こんな宗教っていうのは
神やら仏様 阿弥陀様 これは人間が勝手に作っているものだと
自分の意見書いてるんですね
自分の都合で勝手に作っているものだと
どうったことないと それで先生がすごく嫌な気分になっちゃって
返事できなくなったんですね
すごい立派な子でしたけどね
頭が良くて だって言ってることは本当ですからね
それで その子は阿弥陀様は嘘や
神様の概念が嘘や 人間の妄想だと知ってるんです
いわゆる存在しないと
しかし自分は存在するでしょ
哲学もすべての宗教も私見のカテゴリーです
世の中で人間の数と同じぐらい宗教もあるでしょ
まあ作るは作るは作るは
神様も人間の作品なんですよ
私の国でむかしむかしね
1956年に総理大臣になった人が
かなりの頭のいい立派な人で
本を書いてありまして
そちらにあった文章は
このまあベートーヴェンも同じことを言ってますけど
マンクリエイトドゴッド
本の中にある一つの文章なんですね
この人はもともとキリスト教でしたけど
仏教徒になったんですね
そこでワイアイビケンブディストという本を書いて
そちらにあるのは このゴッドクリエイトドマンというふうに教えて教えられたんだけど
ディスはメンクリエイトドゴッド
神が人間を作ったのではなく
人間が神を作ったんだよと
それが正しくて どんな宗教も人間の意見なんです
頭で概念をゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャかき回してかき回して
宗教はいろいろ作る それで人殺しまでやっている
たまにものから離れることができても
自分の意見を捨てることはできません
あの人殺しやってるイラクとかシリア
いろんなところでね あれ
宗教でしょ あの殺しやってるの
宗教に洗脳されて それから宗教で言って言ってあっても
言ってなくても 自分の私見を作るんですね
だって西洋が悪いと ナイジェリアでね
ボコハラムという運動があるでしょ
西洋教育はやめましょうと言って
200 200人ぐらいの自分の子供女の子たちを誘拐して売りに出しますと
それからも 20人誘拐しちゃったんです
なんだこれはね 西洋が悪いと言ったっても
明らかに誰が悪いんですかね
いくらなんでも西洋人はそんなことはしませんよ
アメリカはね たくさん人権侵害をして
イラクで それアフガニスタンでいろんなところで人を殺してるでしょ
でもああいうやり方じゃないんですね
しかし もう頭がいかれちゃって
自分たちが神のなんだらかんだらと
自分たちは神を守らなくちゃあかんのと
あの連中の神っていうのはもう腰抜けですね
あんな恐ろしい人間に守ってくれないと
そこはおかしいとわかるな
神は偉大なるやつを謳っているでしょうね
だったら神のことは放っておけばいいでしょうに
神にてめえのことてめえで面倒を見てくださいと
だって戦地洗脳でしょうにと
なんでろくに食い物もない連中が人を殺さなくちゃあかんですかね
神のために バカバカらしいでしょ
でも私がそう一級意見ですけど
その方々には自分の意見が正しいんです
どうしようもないんです
それであの恐ろしい人々も
あの決まりですからね
ラマダンの時とかは あの自分の収入から 2.5パーセントない人々に寄付しなさいとか
なんかやってます やってます
で 楽に 例えばビンラディンなんかは金持ちでしょ
知識人でもエンジニアでもあったし
すごい贅沢に生活することはできたんです
それは捨てたんです しかし
ビンラディンになかなか捨てられなかったのは
自分のあの原理主義なんですね
頭イカれた原理主義なんです
だから人は時々物は捨てます
自分の楽しみも捨てます
贅沢も捨てます しかし
意見だけは絶対捨てないんです
できません これは一のウパーダナよりも強い執着になります
そこで皆様方は この執着といったら
物に執着 金に執着することやと思っていたでしょ
そんなもんじゃないんです
もっとあるんです 意見に執着することはものすごい恐ろしいんです
金に執着することでも戦争まで起きますからね
中国も興奮して乱暴なことをやっているし
あれは物に執着して で
裏に意見に執着するっていうこともあります
そこが一番怖いんです
はい それでは 2番目 意見に執着する
すごいひどいものですよ
ひどい執着です 私たちみんなそれで悩んでいるんです
3番目の執着に入ります
ね 儀式 儀礼 行などへの執着
これはよく聞いてください
これは理解しないとわからない執着なんです
儀式 儀礼が好きという疑問
はてなを入れたんです
なぜ好きでないという人もいますからね
これは二よりも強い執着です
そこで覚えてください
お釈迦様が執着は 4つだよと
すべての生命にあるんだよとおっしゃっているんだから
私には 1と2があるんだけど
3はない  4はないとかね
これは言えません  4つもあるんです
もう一人あるでしょう
生きているんだからあり得る
あるんです 確実に  3はどうですかね
3は 2よりも強いんです
自分の心にこの執着があることに気づかないんです
私は自由な人間だと勘違いしている人々も結構います
私はそんなしきたりなんかはやらない
私は自由 偉い 偉いこと言ってますけどね
あれは勘違いです 残念です
脳がマンネリ習慣 習性が好きです
人間でしょ 脳で生きてるでしょ
嘘を言ったらあかん 脳がマンネリが好きなんです
習性が好きなんです 習慣が好きなんです
マンネリで生きで生きられるならば
脳は混乱しないで 判断に悩まないで怠けて活動することはできます
例えば皆様に これからあなたは死ぬまで外国で
南アフリカでナイジェリアで生活しなくちゃいけないやと
退職するまでと会社から追い出されたら困るでしょ
もう困ります なぜどこだって生きていることだから
やっぱり慣れてるんですよ
こちらで あのマンネリが変えたくないんです
全く違う生き方をしたくないんです
そんなもん 誰にでもあります
だから脳が怠けたいんです
すべてオートにして オートパイロットにして
脳が怠けたい 脳が怠けると脳が破壊するんです
何でもかんでもオートパイロットでできるわけじゃないんです
すべて無常だから だからしっかり脳がオートパイロットが欲しいんですね
例えばもう痒くなったらもう何のことなく考えてないんです
マンネリで もう掻いてるんです
だからオートノマスナーバスシステムって英語で言いますけど
この自由でオートで動くように神経システムほとんどなんです
例えば痒くなったら手のこういうところ痒くなりました
では右手を挙げて書きましょうという感じはしません
もう掻いてるんです それでなんであんた手を掻いてるのかといったら
だって痒かったんだから
あれは嘘です 痒いと感じる前に手が動いてるんです
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想では
そのマンネリをできるだけ手動モードにしようとしているんです
それで脳が開発するんです
だからオートになってます
ほとんどの脳の中は 私たちの人生は様々なしきたり
習慣 決まり 規則 儀式 儀礼などでいっぱいです
あれ 宗教に限ってないんです
会社にいたっても朝礼とか何かくだらないことあるでしょうに
なんのために よくわかりませんだけど
学校でもあるでしょうに
で みんな猿みたいに何かいろんな項目をいくつか出して
これ読み上げたりして
私は恥ずかしさでしょうがないんだけど
いい大人がそんなことをやるのかいと
結局は儀式儀礼いっぱいで
この間思い出したのは
この ブッシュじゃなくて
オバマが日本に来たでしょ
その時 日本政府はものすごい必死になっちゃって
国賓で来てほしいと オバマは仕事に来たんだから
仕事をしてさっさと帰りたかったんですね
2 日間しかいなかったし
国賓で国賓でとかね まあしょうがない
日本の危険も取った方がアメリカの都合がいいということで認めたんですね
それでこの国賓儀礼 テレビで NHK で派手にやってますね
バカバカらしくてもう笑っちゃうんですね
あの時間全く無駄なんですよ
ちゃんと天皇陛下と皇后様が出迎えに来て
それで軍隊に あの なんて言いますか
この隊列がありますからね
サリュートね そこに案内ところで偉いなんか誰かが来て
そのオバマさんとちょこちょこ毎回やって面白くないだろうと思います
だからオバマさんもすごく我慢して行くんですね
あの時間で大事なディスカッション何かやればね
役に立つでしょ 総理大臣しゃべる時間10分伸ばして
他の関係の人としゃべる時間10分10分伸ばしたりとかしたら
天皇陛下も楽でしょ あの
なんて言いますか このランチタイムかディナー
それだけ行いますよとかね
そこをやって 迎える儀式やって
それから出迎えの儀式があって
完璧儀式でしょ あれ 派手にやるんだから
だからこの ああいう偉いところでも儀式ばっかしなんですよ
だから偉そうなこと言ったらあかんですよ
人間が儀式好きなんです
別に宗教に限ってないんです
だからカトリック教はもう儀式そのものでしょうに
そこで教育と稽古 人は教育
稽古などで大人になっていくのです
社会に適応しなくてはいけないからです
生まれたら社会に適応しなくちゃあかんでしょ
やっぱり教育稽古しなくちゃあかん
この現実は三のシーラとウパーダナを作るんです
はめられてます 人間なら教育稽古しなくちゃいけない
社会に適応するために
教育っていうのは いろんなこういう儀式
儀礼的なマンネリを叩くことなんです
稽古は当たり前でしょう
訓練ってのは当たり前でしょ
何かマンネリにマンネリでできるようにするんです
マンネリ 習慣などは禁止したら人は不安になります
生きられなくなります
例えば人を家に呼ぶ 晩御飯に来てくださいと
何のマンネリもなくなっちゃうと
家に入ってどうすればいいんですかね
わからなくなっちゃうでしょ
だからやっぱり儀式だり作るんです
お客さんをちゃんと じゃあいらっしゃいと呼ばなくちゃいけない
家の中に そこで はい ここで座ってください
座らせなくてはいけない
で 奥さんが台所で料理を作っている
決してお客さんが台所に行って
そのままパクパクと取って食べません
これは行儀違反ですね
それで食事をちゃんと用意したら
日本だったらまあいただきますとか
あるいはくだらない話を
だろうと思いますけど
まあ乾杯とかなんとかやって
それから食べるでしょ
決まってますよ 仕来りは
みんな乾杯すると一人
私は儀式やりませんよとこうやって手を組んでいたらどうなる？おかしいでしょ
やっぱり執着です それは自由がないんです
決まりありますよ の中で
こういうものなくなっちゃうとどうすればいい？どうすればいい
どうすると判断できなくなるんです
だから 人間の脳にその場で
その場ですぐ判断できる能力はないんです
だから仕来りを作るんです
挨拶にも仕方があって
合ってるかなって どうでもいいんです
仕来りさえ守れば皆安全だと
そういうわけで 私たちにはしきたり
習慣 儀式 儀礼 行などがないと
もう不安で不安で生きていられなくなります
だから必ずあります 国が共産主義であろうか
宗教のない国であろうか
関係なくあります 麻薬のように本格的に依存して生きています
儀式に古い習慣がなくなりますが
代わりにたくさん習慣
たくさんの習慣 決まりを作ってそれらに依存しています
例えば江戸時代の習慣はもうないんですよ
その代わりに江戸時代よりもたくさん今あるんです
今 携帯のマナーまで作らなくちゃあかんだからね
携帯のマナーなど作らなくちゃいけないんだから
その中でも宗教は代物です
宗教は本当にいろんなマナーに仕来りを作るんです
例えば必ず祈らなくてはとかね
祈りは命や祈れ祈りとかね
神を信仰する場合は 祈りがひどいひどい儀式なんです
祈りを信じるんです 信仰があってもなくても
修行とは苦行だと思っているでしょうし
みんなもう宗教に興味ないんだけど
修行すると言った途端
何か普通の楽な生活をやめて
何か難しいことをやっているでしょうと思っちゃうんですね
だから結局は脳の中に入っているんです
この儀式儀礼 意味があってもなくても
何かをやり続けることを賛嘆する
これは日本によくあります
どんなアホなことでも
10年 15年 20年すーっとやると褒めるんです
NHK でも取り上げられるんです
どんなくだらないことでもいいんです
だからマンネリになっちゃってすーっとやってるんですよ
ある人が出したんですけど
この空き瓶を集める 大学の教授ですけど
いろんな古い空き瓶をね
形の違うもの 結構大量に溜まっているんです
だから この使い捨ての空き瓶を拾うことによって
自分がいろいろ苦しいことがあって
いろんなこのもういじめられたり
また失望したり もうなんで私が生きているのかとかね
なんか社会にいらん人間ではないかと思って悩んでいるときは
昔のこの捨てた何か小さな瓶を見つけたんですね
この瓶は昔使って 今誰も使わない
捨てられているんだ それで自分と何か一体感が感じちゃって
私の人生もこれと同じだと
それからこの人は捨ててる瓶を集めるようになっちゃったんです
ある程度で知識ある人だから
いろんな古い瓶をね 集まって集めているんです
そこで NHK で取り上げているんだから
だから だからそこはその人の儀式になっているんです
何かの習慣を守れば救われるという気持ちは本格的な執着になります
そこで これさえ守れば私の命が助かりますと思ったら
ブッダが否定している執着
束縛なんです 念仏さえ唱えておけば OK と言ったら
執着です 恐ろしい執着です
で 前例を受けておけば
みんな天国に行くんだと思ったら執着です
もう救われません そういう風に
これさえやっておけば我は救われると思ったら
これはすごい執着です
そこで宗教ない人々は
まあ家族の面倒を見て
子供の教育をしてあげて
一人前にしてあげて まあそれでまあ写真でも撮ったり
ハイキングでもして まあのんびりしねば大丈夫だと
それで救われますよと
それも執着です 無宗教の人々は社会の決まりを守るだけで十分だと執着を作る
そこで無宗教の人々さえもこの執着を持っています
無宗教の人々は 特にこの無神論者の人々は
宗教を持ってる人々よりも行儀がいいんです
道徳を守っているんです
神を信じている人々はものすごく怖いんです
人を裏切るんです 性格が悪いんです
神を否定する人々は 結構社会のしきたりを守って
行儀作法を守って 道徳を守っては生きているんです
この人々はこれで十分
神がいないんだからと
それがその人々の執着になるんです
脳は習慣で マンネリで決まったパターンで働くようになっているんです
心はこの性質を作っているから
脳も同じ構成になります
そこで脳は勉強できますからね
心の勉強できませんだけど
脳を調べる脳科学者たちが
あの脳は何でもマンネリで動いているんだと
すべて決まっているパターンで
しっかりハードワイヤリングして
こうやって動いているんだと説明するんです
これやったのは心なんです
心がマンネリ好きなんです
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想する人々には
私たちは 1時間以上歩く瞑想をしてくださいと
こういうのをすべて破るためなんで
歩くことはマンネリでできます
オートもパイロットでできます
だからオートパイロットでしないんです
わざと実況中継しながら歩くんです
で 執着を断つためなんです
例外もあります 例外と習慣の悪性
あ 私はわざと習性の悪性とかいたんです
もうダジャレの気持ちで
ある程度で社会の決まりを守らなくてはならない
で 普遍的な道徳を守らなくてはならないでしょ
瞑想にしても 繰り返して行って習慣にしなくてはならない
でないとできないんです
しかし しがみつくこと
これはパラマアーサという専門用語なんです
この習慣にしがみつく
これやこれやと溺れる人が浮き輪にしがみつくような感じ
これだけは捨てませんよと
だからある程度で習慣ありますよ
しかし しがみつくことをやめちゃおうと
やめましょうと それが執着なんですね
習性ではなく パラマースが悪性なんです
あの道徳とか挨拶の習慣とかね
それは大丈夫です パラマースなんです
しがみつくことが悪性なんです
じゃあしがみつかないんだけど
たくさん習慣持っている
それは OK です 悪性ではない
捨てる構え 改良する構えが必要です
いつでも習慣は改良しなくちゃいけない
悪い習慣ならポイと捨てる能力が必要です
しがみついちゃうとできない
特に宗教組織が困っているところはそこなんですね
古い文化化石で 昔からやっていることはずっと
これは 200年もやっているんだ
300年もやっている
勝手にやってくださいと
面白くないんだけど この仏像はもう何て言いますか
100年に一回しか見せませんよと言ったら
おばあさんたちが並んで行ってみる
見る必要ないんです そんなに隠して
ずっと隠しておけと なんだこりゃと
見てもくっだらないものなんです
だからそういう場合は
一般人から宗教から一般人が離れていくんですよ
それで困るんだけど どうしようこともわからない
こう 執着なんですね 煩悩なんですよ
宗教家の だから一般人よりは宗教聖職者には煩悩がありすぎなんです
一般人よりは性格悪すぎなんです
付き合ってみてください
私はごめんです 人の道は客観的に観察することのみ
物事だと発見すると この煩悩は消えます
いわゆるオートモードではないんだと
オートモードは何とかしなくちゃと
すぐ客観的にデータを見てみて
みて 判断しなくちゃいけないんだと
すべて無常やと 何が起こるかわからないんだと
すべて想定の通りに起こるわけじゃないんだと
すべて想定外やと思った方がものすごい能力が上がるんです
決まってる 決まってると思ったら
ひどい目にあいます これは仏教では気づきの実践というのです
4番目の執着 ではもうわかるでしょう
皆様が偉そうなこと言わないでください
私たちにはそんなしきたり
儀式 そんなのはないんだよと
脳みそを持ってるならば
脳みそがオートで仕事するようにできているんです
だから誰にだってあるんです
それからそれがすごい強烈なんです
教育と稽古事で我々大人になるんだから
他の大人になる方法はないんです
だから 五欲への執着よりはものすごいたちが悪い
確実に働く執着なんです
4番目 アッタワドゥーパーダーナ
我論への執着 で飛ばしましょう
最強の執着は我論です
自分の体 感覚 思考 感情などは自分だ
自我だと錯覚することはサッカーヤディッティといいます
専門用語で有身見というのです
意味は上に書いたもの
自分の体 自分の思考 自分の感情
あれ 私です 私です 私ですと同一視化するんですよ
体に これ私ですと 気持ちに
え 私ですと 考えに え 私ですと
これって錯覚なんです
考えは考えで私ではありません
だって考えは変化するでしょ
感情は感情であって 常に変化するんだから
私ではありません 肉体は肉体の勝手で変わって壊れるんだから
私ではありませんだけど
そちらに全部私 私って私と言わない場合は
私の私の私のと言うんです
それで私は見つからない
私の思考 私の考え 私の気持ち
私の感情 私の体 私の鼻
私の目 私の脳みそ 全部私のですけど
肝心の私はどこにいるのかというといないんです
だからこれ明確に錯覚なんです
自分という何かがある
自分という実体があると信じることですね
これが 誰でも自分に執着しているんです
誰にだって私という 強烈にあるんです
ない人はいません 犬猫にもあります
この愛着は捨てられませんね
捨てたくもありませんね
だから強烈です 最強です
無常・苦・無我を発見して預流果
いわゆる悟りの第一ステージに達するまでなくなりませんよ
かなり強力です この有身見はなくなりません
錯覚です すべての苦を作る
この有身見で自分がいるから様々な問題が起こるんです
自我の錯覚があるから
憂い 悲しみ 悩み 苦しみが生まれるんです
自我の錯覚があるから煩悩が現れるんです
論争 戦い 争い 武器を持つことなどが起こるんです
武器の製造 販売 全部自我の錯覚で起こるんです
殺畜 奪い合いなどが起こるんです
最強の執着です これが一番悪い
一番奇想になる執着 束縛です
自分がないと勝手に思い込むことも虚無主義で
これも煩悩です だからって勝手に私がいませんと言ったってもね
いるんだから それは虚無主義で煩悩です
智慧が現れない限りは破れない執着です
この執着 束縛を破るためには智慧
ブッダに説かれた智慧
智慧とは無常 苦 無我を発見することです
それしか方法ないんです
自我の錯覚が消えても
自分という実感あるんです
預流果に達しても 自分という実感が残ります
では 悟りの第一ステージに達して自我がないとわかるんです
でも悟り完了してないんです
まあ自我はないんだけど
自分という実感だけは残るんですね
実体 自我がないと発見しています
有身見もなくなってます
執着一は減っているが
微妙に残っています 執着一っていうのは欲への
執着 五欲への もう減ってます
何としてでも美味しいものを食わなくちゃはないんです
何か食べればいい 何としてでも大金持ちにならなくちゃないんです
適当に金があれば生きていられるんだと
減ってます が 残っているんです
二 サカダーミ これは一来果と言うんです
三 アナガーミ 不還果と言うんです
四 アラハット 阿羅漢果という順番で達するたびに自分という実感が減って消えていきます
すごい質が悪いんです
夜中に悟った人はもう一度ヴィパッサナー瞑想を最初からスタートするんです
それでまたあのプログラムを全部最初からやって
2番目の悟りに達する
そうすると あの実感がもうちょっと減るんです
またヴィパッサナー実践をやって
3番目の悟りに達する
もうちょっと減るんです
何が減るかというと あの 2番目になると
あの怒りと欲がすごく弱くなる
3番目に悟ったら 怒りと欲が消える
他の煩悩は残っている
4番目に悟ったら全部煩悩が消える
本当はそんなたくさん煩悩が消えるんじゃなくて
モチが消えるんです 一個だけです
消えるのは それで根元から切っちゃったら木が倒れるんです
自分という実感が減って消えていきます
4番目に達しない限りは
自分という実感が残るんです
執着一はサマタ瞑想でロックアウトすることはできます
執着一は しかし  1から4までなくす方法は瞑想実践のみです
そんな思うほど簡単じゃないんです
執着を達して自由になるということは
パンニャーバーヴァナ
ヴィパッサナーという実践ですね
あの瞑想瞑想言ったっても
宗教でおっしゃっている瞑想とは違います
科学的な観察することなんです
あの脳のあのオートパイロットモードを一旦停止させて
手動で脳を動かしてみるんです
それだけなんです それで成長するんです
はい それで一応講演は終わります
これ後書きなんです なんで後書きしたのかというと
この説明の文章にアラティという単語がオンリーというふうに書いてあったんですね
それについてちょっと説明したくなりました
本当は私は昨日たくさんいろいろ経典下がったんだけど
これに対してたくさん調べたんです
本格的なテーマにはほとんど苦労しなかったんです
欲にラティといいますが
反対のアラティは解脱ではありません
欲から煩悩から執着から離れる場合は
ニッビンダティ ヴィラッジャティ
ヴィムッチャティという言葉を使うんです
アラティという言葉を使わないんです
ニッビンダティ ヴィラッジャティはオンリーという意味で
意味で ヴィムッチャティは自由になる
解放される 解脱するという意味です
だからアラティという言葉は使わないんです
欲から離れることを意味するとき
ヴィラティという言葉を使われることもあります
たまにあります その時
必ず五欲を対象にして使われています
五欲に対してアラティ使いますけど
欲のない解脱の状態を表現するためにアラティという単語を使いません
では アラティの意味はなんでしょうかね
アラティ やる気を失うという意味なんです
使うわけないでしょ 仏教は
アラティっていうのは現代用語でうつなんです
これ病気なんです 心は常に活性化した状態でなければいけません
欲ではなく 喜びを感じなくてはなりません
欲は束縛で執着でダメです
しかし 喜びを感じてほしい
喜びと欲は同じものだと思わないでください
喜びは別なものです 欲で喜ぶ場合もあります
しかし 喜びは別です 慈悲喜捨の喜の実践では
心に意図的に喜びを経験させるんです
皆様方 知っている慈悲の瞑想で喜の実践というものがあるんですね
私はえっと 私の何でしたっけ？願うことが叶えられますようにという文章
その時は 私の願い事はもうとっくに叶っていますよと
うまく行ってるんだよと
その充実感を感じる 実感するんです
意図的にそれを育てるんです
これはのうつに対する
あの 何といいますか 治療方法です
そこでお坊さんたちも時々うつになります
ケースたくさんあります
お釈迦様の弟ですけど
結婚するその日で お釈迦様が出家させたでしょ
なんで？と言うんですね
弟だから 弟は王家の人々だから
命令に必ず従うんです
だからお釈迦様に食事を差し上げて
明日の結婚式の前にお釈迦様にも接待しようと
お釈迦様が鉢を上げてこれ持ってと言ったんです
言ったらすぐ取り戻すであろうと思っていたんだけど
お釈迦様は衣をすくってそのまま出ちゃったんです
出ちゃったら ナンド王子がどうしようもなく後ろから行くんですね
行って お釈迦様自分がお泊まりになるところに行ったら
あ ナンド お前 突然見たような感じで
あんた出家したらどう？断れなくなっちゃったんです
もういいですよと もう次の日結婚式なんです
で 出家しちゃったんです
釈迦族だからプライドあるんですよ
だから真面目に戒律を守って修行したんですけど
やるのやっちゃったんです
奥さんのことを思い出しちゃって
すごい美人と結婚する予定でしたからね
うつになっちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様がそれにちゃんとした
ちょっとショックトリートメントをあげて
この気持ちを変えちゃったんです
で まあそれは有名な話で
修行者もね 例えば瞑想するはするはするはするは
どうも成長する気配はない
ああ なんだこれはねと思っちゃいますよ
やる気がなるなくなっちゃうんです
それもうつなんです  やってもやってもこんなもんでね
成長するわけないでしょうと
だから結構うつが攻撃します
うつに使う言葉は仏教用語でアラティなんです
喜びとは欲ではなく 心にやる気
意欲を与えることでも
努力した分 充実感 ご褒美を感じることでも
だから仏教では粗き薄はダメです
すごく喜びを感じてほしい
うまく生きているんだと
大丈夫だと 人生は 頑張った分結果があるんでしょうと
だから悩んだり落ち込んだりしては決していけません
それのだけの仕事うまくいってるんだな
あんな程度の喜びは足らない
脳いっぱい 細胞いっぱい喜びを感じるようにしなくちゃあかんです
するとものすごい元気になるんです
体中喜びあふれるようにしなくちゃいけないんです
それにはヴィパッサナーの瞑想をする羽目になるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想するときでも
心が妄想から離れて何もない
ただ客観的な実況だけの世界に入っていることに喜びを感じなくちゃあかん
その時が本当は幸福 楽
シャーですけど 感じるのはね
それでも頑張ってるんだと
ご褒美を心にあげた方がいいんです
頑張ってる それがもう栄養剤ですよ
心の成長の だから喜び感じてほしい
欲はダメ だって人は山登っても喜び感じるでしょ
あれって楽じゃないでしょ
だから苦からも喜び感じますよ
すごい難しい試験であっても
ものすごい苦労して受験勉強すると
やるぞと思っちゃえば受験中も喜び感じます
それで合格したらものすごい喜びを感じます
これは欲じゃないんです
受験合格したら楽しくてたまらなくなります
それは OK です これは脳の栄養剤になります
はい こういうことで講演は終了です
仏道を実践して 今日のスローガンです
思い存分 エキサイトメントアンドコンテンメント
この喜び英訳すると本当はエキサイトメントなんですね
で 脳がなんとなくやる気が出ている
コンテンメントというのは充実感なんですね
頑張っていること その二つをね
感じましょうと これは仏道しか与えません
他の世の中にも楽しいこといっぱいあるんだけど
すべて麻薬みたいに自己破壊のものなんです
仏教は世界一有名なタレントさんが来て
舞台劇場をやったっても
それより何の副作用もない
すごい純粋な清らかな喜びを与えてあげるんです
はい 終了です どうもありがとうございます
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますよう
サッビーテオヴィヴァンジャントーサンベローコウィナッサトーマハンテーヴァヴァントアンテラーヨスティーディーガーユコーバウェバウトサッバマンガラン
ラッカントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバブッダーヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマーヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバヴァントーティー
アビナーダナシーリッサニッチャンワンターパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーダンティー
アーユアンノースパンバラン
サードサードサー  はい
長い時間本当にご苦労様でした
どうもありがとうございます